19 and 19 through 38 games  that's a whale of a way to start a  quarter yes  for that  the winners of two in a row  even dwayne casey said winning two games  gets you confident  wow dustin robinson out of virginia tech  gets a three and starts growing  tonight  the hornets are gonna put what should be  a 14-game winning streak against the  pistons on the line  [Applause]  all right we have uh luca garza in the  game for the first time  rookie out of iowa last year he was the  college player of the year that's the  fifth three-pointer of the quarter  [Applause]  kelly  oh my six in the corner 18 points for  kelly of the fourth right now the  hornets are owning  the pistons again kelly  oh  my god  [Music]  smith into the ball game for the sole  purpose of setting up kelly shoot it  from sardis road  are you kidding me